at the beginning of 2020 a barrel of US
crude oil cost around $60 then came the
corona virus pandemic forcing states to
order lock downs emptying streets
closing businesses and shuttering
factories across the nation demand dried
up and the price fell to $18 on Monday
things took a catastrophic turn for the
first time in history US oil went into
negative territory a doomsday scenario
for the entire industry President Trump
called the drop interesting despite the
crash hitting the stock market we're
filling up our national petroleum
reserves strategic you know the
strategic reserves and we're looking to
put as much as 75 million barrels into
the reserves themselves that would top
it out that would be first time in a
long time it's been tapped out would get
it for the right price capacity though
both on land and at sea in the United
States is filling up since March
stockpiles in some locations have risen
by 50% in some places the price of fuel
is now at a 10-year low demand is down
there's no certainty when states will
reopen and all this comes as a severe
blow to President Donald Trump he's gone
to great lengths to protect the oil
sector working with both Russia and OPEC
to reduce production now the entire
global industry is in an unprecedented
crisis the historic deal to slash
production by millions of barrels a day
involved Saudi Arabia Russia and other
oil-producing nations but experts say
another global effort is needed
we're probably down a million from our
normal 10 million barrels down to about
nine that probably needs to come down
some more but all the other
oil-producing countries need to do the
same until the economy recovers the
plunging prices are driven by trading
deadlines oil is traded on its future
price contracts are due to expire on
Tuesday buy as a virtually non-existent
some traders are now paying to get rid
of oil instead of buying it the
president says the industry will bounce
back they got caught and
there are a lot of people that are not
too happy because they got caught so if
you take a look at it you'll see it's
more of a financial thing than an oil
situation but because you take I believe
in a month or so in other words go a
little bit out it's at twenty five and
twenty eight dollars a barrel so it's
largely a financial squeeze if there is
a silver lining those on the front lines
of the coronavirus will pay less to fuel
their cars a recovery in demand for oil
is now dependent on a crisis that in
many parts of the US is far from over
Andy Gallacher al Jazeera Miami Florida
al Jazeera sambandh Javaid has more from
Doha now on the impact that oil price
drop may have in the Middle East it has
a number of repercussions for the Gulf
economy is predominantly for leader
status now the Arabia which has been
trying to control the way the markets
have been acting to the amount of oil
that has been getting in the last few
weeks you've seen Saudi Arabia going
from a production cut to a glut to a cut
again and now you see that this massive
drop it we are at a point in oil prices
which wasn't seen and the last time we
saw the likes of it was in nineteen
forty six that was right after the
second world war it is going to have an
impact on economies such as Bahrain and
Oman which do not have the kind of deep
sovereign wealth funds that other
countries have it is going to have an
impact on OPEC second-largest producers
such as Iraq which has been struggling
to pay salaries for its employees these
are state employees which have not been
paid in full it is going to have an
impact on the soldiers on the front
lines that Iraq is going to have to find
money not just to continue its fight
against ISIL but also to continue its
fight against the corona virus pandemic
remember that iraq is already asking for
donors to chip in to help it meet this
crisis so it is going to have impact
which is going to be far and wide in
terms of economics but it is also going
to have an impact on the political
economy of Saudi Arabia which is seen as
a regional leader because of its
currency that it has not just with
America and the Russians but also in
terms of how it dominates the region